arc length here is referred to as s so  we have a formula s equals R theta there  relates the radius a central angle and  the arc the only thing is to use this  formula theta has to be in radians so if  they give you the angle the central  angle in degrees just convert it to  radians then you can use this  relationship s equals our theta so let's  look at an example say we have a circle  like this say the radius equals 10  centimeters say this angle here is PI  over 4 radians and we want to find out  what that arc length is right there s so  what we're going to do is we're going to  use our formula s equals R theta the  radius is 10 the angle is PI over 4 and  if we multiply those together we get 10  PI over 4 which reduces down to 5 PI  over 2 centimeters that's an exact  answer for the length of that arc